making friends here is sometimes what  saves people's lives  or what gets him up out of bed in the  morning  i am a teacher for helping hands a sign  language community here in vr chat hand  rested under our elbow and we're gonna  go like this christmas  slow  quick quick slow if i had confidence  that i could teach dance as a living in  vr i totally would do exactly that with  a long distance relationship having vr  is a game changer we are 5 000 miles  apart but we're gonna try our best to  make it work  this year has been really hard  the thing that has kept me sane has been  vr and the vr community  i would not have weathered this without  you guys  you can be who you've always wanted to  be  and you can in a way start over  we can come together and support each  other this community means a lot to me  and i really want them to know that  they're loved  it's true been a year since i've seen  kevin's irl body  [Music]  you